[Musique]
c'est avec hélène fera bon jour hélène
bonjour pauline à la une ce matin la
victoire des socialistes aux
législatives anticipées au portugal
absolute absolue a annoncé ce matin au
diario de noticias le ps d'antonio costa
parvient même à décrocher la majorité
absolue écrasant au passage le bloc de
gauche et la coalition communistes verts
et ouvrant aussi une crise à droite chez
ses adversaires du psd après six ans de
gouvernement deux ans de pandémie une
campagne erratique 1 tonne cost a réussi
ce qu'il avait demandé timidement le
jour nord de new tissage évoque la
victoire écrasante des socialistes
prouvant le choix sans équivoque je cite
des portugais en faveur de la stabilité
une victoire qui dispensent le ps de
toutes négociations pour former un
nouveau gouvernement la civic la
stabilité oui mais un changement de
taille paulina également puisque pour la
première fois depuis la révolution de
1974 l'extrême droite va désormais
pouvoir peser sur les débats au
parlement où le parti chez aig à ses
totalise désormais 12 députés contre un
seul auparavant devenant ainsi la
troisième force politique du pays selon
son patron andré ventu la cité par uche
presse on va parler de la politique en
france maintenant christiane taubira a
quant à elle remporté hier la primaire
populaire de la gauche l'un forte de
cette victoire l'ex ministre de la
justice a exprimé sa volonté de
rassembler le début d'un élan ou une
candidature de plus libération rappelle
qu'aucun des autres candidats de gauche
à l'elysée n'a l'intention de se ranger
derrière christiane taubira elle sait
que c'est pour rire demande jean luc
mélenchon le patron des insoumis à
yannick jadot le chef d'europe écologie
les verts dans le dessein de cac publié
par l'opinion qui présente la victoire
de christiane taubira comme une
humiliation vous venez de l'évoquer pour
la socialiste annie d anne hidalgo j'en
perds mon latin arrivé en cinquième
position à cette primaire populaire la
droite évidemment boit du petit-lait le
figaro voit la gauche se réveiller ce
lundi matin toujours fracture et ses
divisions réduisant la sincérité des
quatre cent mille votants à cette
primaire populaire à un simple et
prévisible gâchis en ukraine
l'incertitude demeure sur les projets
militaires de la russie d'après la croix
les craintes d'un conflit s'immisce dans
toutes les conversations en ukraine mais
la population habituée à vivre avec la
menace russe continue de vivre
normalement le calme des ukrainiens
tranche avec l'agitation du premier
ministre britannique qui a affirmé ce
week end préparé je le cite un
déploiement majeur de troupes deux
navires de guerre et d'avions de combat
en europe une déclaration martiale
tourner en dérision par les dessinateurs
de presse outre-manche qui accuse beau
joe de chercher en réalité à détourner
l'attention du scandale du parti gates
dans le dessein de morton moerlen
bladinières routine reprend d'ailleurs
un son argumentaire sur les fêtes à
downing street en justice sur la
présence des troupes russes par un
rendez vous de travail ou encore ce
cartoon pauline signé nicolas jennings
montrant bozzo boris johnson en tenue de
camouflage à la frontière ukrainienne
trahi par la bouteille qu'il cache
derrière son doux et des nouvelles de la
can à présent et de l'open d'australie
on à l'egypte qualifié hier soir face au
maroc pour la demi finale de la can
les phares hommes ont vaincu les lions
de l'atlas a lu le journal égyptien al
masry al youm
rendez vous ce jeudi face aux lions
indomptables du cameroun
qualification en demi-finale également
hier soir du sénégal qui a défait la
guinée équatoriale et rencontrera samedi
le burkina faso annonce seneweb est bien
sûr impossible de vous dire à tout à
l'heure sans mentionner bien sûr la
victoire formidable de rafael nadal en
finale de l'open d'australie le champion
espagnol ajoute une 21e couronne en
grand chelem à son palmarès soit une de
plus c'est un corridor federer et novak
djokovic
ce qui en fait le plus grand tennisman
de l'histoire elmer rôle de leicester et
la nasa à 35 ans selon elle il est trop
fort merci beaucoup c'était la revue de
presse est avec nous on se retrouve dans
une quinzaine de minutes pour un nouveau
journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]